my other thought goes to a place where
a jamie diamond a uh uh
warren buffett a dalio take any of these
guys that
already have a lot of power and
influence they sit there and say why
would i use bitcoin why don't i come up
with my own you know cryptocurrency
that uh a uh uh chase is gonna use i
have power what about if i bring the
smartest guys and they start mining they
start doing the same exact 50 25 12 and
a half six and a quarter
three and an eight and then boom you go
all the way down let's do the same thing
let's put the same kind of timeline
together
if the formula worked and singapore is
using us's approach
because it worked why don't we use what
worked with bitcoin but let's control it
here within b of a let's control it here
with chase
let's control here with goldman or
morgan whoever it is so if
binance is the direct competitor to
coinbase
who would essentially be the direct
competitor to bitcoin
there there is no competitor to bitcoin
right because bitcoin has the
only thing that actually matters in this
entire game
in order to have a non-state currency
you need full decentralization
if you do not have decentralization you
will fail and the reason why i say that
is because the government has a monopoly
on violence
and so if you are jamie dimon and you
want to create your own currency
which they thought about doing or your
facebook and you want to create your own
currency
which they did right what happens
immediately the government says mark
zuckerberg come in talk to congress
you're not allowed to do this we're
going to make all these changes right
and and this is a no-go
there is no ceo to call in from bitcoin
there's no way to shut it down
decentralization is the security
so the framework i use for this is to
ascend to a global reserve currency
throughout history there was violent
combat one country or one
you know a kind of geographic location
or kingdom
went engaged in combat prevailed
and then installed their currency as the
global reserve currency
but in a digital world the most
powerful military is not the one that is
best offensively
it is the one that is best defensively
so in the analog world whoever's got the
more bombs bullets guns soldiers etc you
have the most military might therefore
you get the global reserve currency
united states is dominating in that
fashion over the last
uh couple of centuries or decades in the
cyber world
if you can simply just keep everyone out
from hacking you then you're the most
powerful
and bitcoin is the strongest computing
network in the world there's no computer
or computer network in the world
stronger than bitcoin it has the best
cyber defense
it is protecting a trillion plus dollar
asset and no one can hack it i don't
care what
government you are what individual what
corporation organization et cetera you
cannot hack bitcoin
because it is so decentralized and has
so much computing power running it
so when you get to that world what ends
up happening is it doesn't matter what
any government says it doesn't matter
what any politician says
they can try to regulate individuals or
corporations but they cannot shut down
the network and that open decentralized
network
naturally value will flow there and so
if jamie dimon wants to start his own
coin
that's a great idea for him to try but
he'll never be successful in getting
global adoption
because he's always going to have to
answer to a government
that says jamie right you are not
allowed to do this
because now you are a direct competition
to our
state currency well let me ask you a
question doesn't doesn't that kind of
make you
the buffet of the world that's too cocky
to think that somebody else can't come
and take you guys like
you know what i'm saying does not kind
of make you make make it be like america
where you become you know complacent too
confident to think that somebody else
can't come and take you out that's my
only thing where i think
it's worked so effectively that
someone's going to say we're going to do
it ourselves and we have a name already
where there's certain competition so you
have to remember that
uh there is a hyper uh uh
in the bitcoin community right and what
i mean by that is
every single day millions of people
around the world
are running the numbers they're
constantly looking at
is the code executing correctly is there
anyone who's trying to do anything
nefarious or malicious
has anybody gotten too much uh computing
power or hash rate on the network like
like this hyper villagence around this
transparent asset
we're talking about an asset that had no
venture funding or any sort of you know
equity capital contributed
it had no team no ceo no founder no
marketing team no partnerships team no
anything
and it got all of these people around
the world to build it
run it protect it etc and it's grown
into a trillion dollar asset and it's
all because incentives run the world
and a decentralized open system is
superior to every other system in the
world
so here's what here's my greatest fear
as jamie dimon and other people start
going into this world
right i've called it the uh the
corporate central uh bank playbook
and i've been writing about this for a
while uh but i think it's a world where
we're going to be
very very scared if we answer this jp
morgan said that they were going to
create jpm coin a while ago
and jpm coin was going to be backed one
to one to the us dollar so they'd put a
bunch of dollars in a bank account right
and they would issue a digital dollar or
jpm coin
and then you would go around you could
use this thing uh and they would start
with their corporate customers right
their partners
then eventually they would push it out
to retail they get merchants using it
etc but then just like the us dollar was
de-pegged from gold
jamie dimon and jp morgan in the future
can just say you know what we're not
going to unpeg it from the dollar
and now all of a sudden jp morgan is in
charge and controls
a currency that has you know global or
national adoption
but they are the central bank they can
print as much as they want contract the
supply as they want et cetera
and so i've been a very big proponent
that they're they're
i'm usually not a very big proponent of
regulation
but there needs to be a conversation
immediately
that if a financial institution goes
ahead
and says we are going to create a
digital currency
and it is backed by a basket of
currencies commodities whatever
that is okay but you are not allowed to
change it in the future
so if you tell people it's back one to
one to the dollar and then you want to
unpeg it in the future
now what we're doing is we're really
threatening the national currencies
because we're going to give corporations
the ability to be central banks
right that's a world i don't think we
want to go into and so when you compare
would you rather a decentralized
transparent monetary
uh system or would you rather jp morgan
control the currency
yeah because then it goes back to the
old school of doing business where one
person's so powerful that you're scared
of them because they can make any
decision that that
makes a lot of sense so by the way i'm a
math guy
you sound like a math guy right you know
when you were back in school and you had
this one tough formula teacher will
write it on the board you're like
holy how and then you would sit there
your brain is just going crazy because
you're trying to really figure this
thing out
who the hell is this person that figured
out the math for
bitcoin the 50 25 12 and a half the
timing every four years
mining how does one even
i mean you know i've interviewed craig
wright before oh i am satoshi and you
know when i did that i you have no idea
how many hate let me
email people you can't i cannot believe
you even had the audacity to have them
on
everyone knows he's not satoshi all this
other person what do you think about
when you think about the person forget
about asking who do you think it is i'm
not asking who do you think it is
what do you think about what it takes
for a person to create
something like this from scratch where a
trillion dollar
asset today what do you think about the
brain it takes to create something like
this
yeah um there's there's two key
components here in my opinion
one is uh there's a beauty in this like
immaculate conception story right nobody
knows who the founder is the
pseudonymity
uh the way it was introduced all that
stuff is actually a key feature of
bitcoin
i don't want to know who it is and i
don't think that it would be necessarily
good for bitcoin if people knew
i don't think it would be fatal either
but i think that having this like
nameless or
or faceless founder is actually a really
strong thing because there's nobody to
point at or to talk to or call in front
of congress all that kind of stuff so i
think that's kind of the first piece is
the satoshi nakamoto almost like legend
is a key component very important the
second thing is
people don't understand that this is
actually not the first iteration
of a attempt at a global digital
currency
right there was bitgold and a couple of
other attempts previously and they
didn't get it right
there was either problems with this
double spend problem or other types of
issues that popped up
and so whoever the individual or group
of people who came up with bitcoin
they actually had some kind of shoulders
to stand on right there was previous
attempts and people were able to kind of
see
okay somebody tried this type of
iteration it didn't work well we can
figure out a solution to that
and so obviously whoever did this
whether it's an individual or a group
incredibly intelligent i mean the design
of bitcoin is beautiful
both from kind of the monetary policy
we've been talking about uh
the uh difficulty uh adjustments that
occur in the mining system etc
but i also think that uh in some crazy
crazy world
it takes humility it takes a humbleness
whoever the individual is or the group
to have created something
and to not say anything to not go move
the you know whatever is 800 000 a
million bitcoin or whatever that's in
the satoshi wallets
that's a lot of money and so when you
start to look at this system
this is a special person or group to not
only have been smart enough to design it
to not only have been smart enough to
introduce it into the system
to also disappear right and to kind of
walk away
but then also not to financially benefit
from it it's pretty incredible when you
start to kind of unpack a lot of this
and i think that uh over the years
satoshi nakamoto will probably end up
being seen as one of the most important
people or groups in the world
and the beauty is we just don't know who
it is so if you like this sort of short
club from an interview i did click over
here to watch the entire
interview and please don't forget to
subscribe to the channel take care
everybody bye